fabi blunder  whoa  okay so he did play f3 and apparently  rook takes d4 here is very strong but  yeah i considered it but it's not  obvious that it's so strong yeah i mean  it's very playable the bishop 6 now is  completely unchallengeable  the white center is broken up i can  easily see this being good for black but  yeah calling this a blunder i think is a  bit harsh  i was just reading out  being played and he also hit 1 000 on  1 000 precious rating points  on one of the websites informed me of it  proudly in one of our  sounds exactly like those people i have  my  daily arguments on my stream about  stepford great opening uh watching this  video their video  magnus won  a  dominant display it's very very  impressive it also clinches the  tournament progress  oh played magnus